in the previous segment of our panel
discussion on ethnic conflict we talked
in particular about the possible innate
psychological roots of ethnic conflict
and ethnic violence now we're going to
broaden the focus and look a bit more at
the economic and political dimension I'd
like to actually shift now from the sort
of micro to very macro you you mentioned
things like Rwanda you mentioned some
sort of very large scale arenas in which
these in which these things can play out
and you know debraj ray I I think
there's a general sense that this kind
of ethnic violence actually has
increased in the last 50 years is kind
of a as kind of a cause of regional and
international human conflict you know is
well first of all is that true and is
there any evidence for that yeah so I
was actually listening to to the other
speakers with quite regular fascination
because rising two he was at a much
broader level in fact this you know two
remarkable facts about social context
which is that first one is that within
country conflicts the comfort enormous
share of the Benson hardship that you
see nothing you look after after World
War true there's been a shame over 20
interstate conflicts you know neither of
them have killed over a thousand people
of the entire history of the conflict
where is there from the same period is
going to be 20 civil conflicts and half
of them have killed more than a thousand
people and the total number of people
dared us orders of magnitude higher than
what you see in interstate was are you
won't want to that's that's the first
interesting pattern things that there's
a lot of internal stuff that's going on
in society but the the second
interesting feature is that if you try
to classify these so called eternal
country some of them would be get a
glass pure and simple in
to see conflict that we actually view
very much as a class olivia is really a
belgium connotation is Belgium Norman
Fletcher 4444 groups of hydrogen lots of
thousands of a post that that kind of
northern pleasure can harden as as we
were pointing our people to return like
that but if you leave out even that
which you a half of these conflicts are
actually everything technique conflicts
so there are several definitions will be
so we're talking about hundreds of
projects that take place over which of
which Mohan a half of them can be
classified previous ethnic violence how
do we how do we actually make that
classification I mean you know you
mentioned class you mentioned you know
as and tell you how do you teach those
things apart actually it certainly this
is just a part is what one looks at is
the different groups that are engaged in
conflict and then you see whether an
ethnic identifier is being used by one
of these or so for example the velocity
is talking about the grievance of the
Serbs would then say that at least one
of this group one of the groups involved
is identifying themselves for a
fundamentally ethnic platform now that
does not mean that the viruses that that
is happenings of primordial violence it
does not follow from that that the
groups are actually engage in fact most
of my research is is dedicated to
showing that what we think of as
primordial violence across groups is
actually economic violence in disguise
so so so the fact that most of this
violence is classified as ethnic people
groups actually classify themselves of
ethnic from that it does not follow that
there are these basic hatreds does not
necessarily follow that that is based in
transparent plans so I got in the case
of the chest near baggage you could
argue that there is a certain in fact
already bar in the certain amount of
intrinsic animosity that has to drive it
if you lots of evidence for its true
meant to animals
so for example the burning of driving
distances that belong to another than
anything and if you just get another
ethnic group why not just attack them at
random why do we attack that I drew
ethnic businessman attack other ethnic
businessman um why do we see you know
certain housing colony to be taken off
so what I'm trying to rip it out why
won't they tie the agreeing with with
the with the frame that social
psychologists take about about the
innate tendency for us in forming groups
about groups whatever the layer on that
is the idea that economic motives can
really wrap it up that affect another
order of magnitude and and really
hardened those those lines in a very
strong wings well what do you think
could you I mean I think that's very
interesting what do you think is is
maybe the best example of of a of an
ethnic conflict or what we would tend to
call an ethnic conflict that's actually
in an economic conflict in disguise um
well example it being an example from
work that I've been going on in the
bosom buddies so it's indian
independence there's been sporadic
outbreaks of human survivors it's hard
to tell by looking at the newspaper
reports whether this is revenge women is
a trip whether there was a rumor spread
about that say a rainproof was there
calm utilized to use a medium term to
starting to a religious issues so far
but one thing that comes across if you
were at the data is that so what we did
was we put together violence data with
economic data from the National Sample
Survey and what you see is that in
regions where there is a jump in Muslim
income relative to get win come those
regions are invariably followed by
licensing very people followed
invariably the statistical sense by
upsurge in violence and so a collection
that you see across the different
regions of India so you got go ahead
sorry Elizabeth I just wanted to see if
I can understand how this might fit with
the
works at Mozza ring and Richard we're
talking about and would you agree that
this is that economics can serve as
another means to sort of identify in
group Nappy it's sort of classic fits in
with those things is that the idea but
you're right but but there's an
interesting difference order for that to
people that remarks is what it marks
avon bodies mark said that most violence
should be four against the venture so a
proposed I'm simplifying but select
class files right now from bunch of the
virus that you see in developing
countries they wear glasses out there
for the taking right as as a as a
salient construct okay we are the poor
there the risk even though it's there
for the taking the lines are drawn in a
very different way so so so so the lines
are drawn in some sense is sometimes
orthogonal plans for nothing sinhala and
tamil it's you don't come right paradox
of it was is that these groups we shall
be demarcated on ethnic lines would
actually be economically quite similar
they'll both be engaged in the same
businesses or they'd both be workers in
the same sector that the textile sector
or the brass where sector of the BD
making sector then they make sense or
say economic similarities across sectors
are often prey are often good targets of
of ethnic markets I completely would
agree that economic economic dimension
is a very important one that makes for
begin an outlet of groups to just pop
out and be visible and ends up being
used in all of the in fact you can sort
of look at you know groups that didn't
used to be a traitor to our economic
well-being we're perfectly life but as
they become threats to our economic
well-being we begin to find them
threatening it East Asians in this
country feminist women these are groups
of people who you know may not have been
attended to as much but a certain kind
of negativity towards them emerges as we
see that they are likely to take the job
of the people who used to have them and
so on so I agree with that but I would
like to say that there is that but there
are many
samples when economic differences aren't
present and you still see evidence of
this in an hour group so so much sorry
excuse me for interrupting but that was
exactly my point that in many situations
we don't see economic differences yeah
the the the markers are created for
grabbing if you'd like the larger share
of a smaller part the reason the bias
models because this conflict and
conflict is always visible but sometimes
you can grab a larger share of a smaller
piont which could be better on the one
point is a body of economics
similarities rather so you both can i
buy the car so you are viewed each agree
that you don't that you don't
necessarily have to have economics to
have this in-group out-group mechanisms
or operate us the faculty of economics
authorities across the cruise does not
negate the fact that the conflicts
between them easy kaname okay i
understand so oh but I do agree that
other nations are you sure you start to
look at simple things like my feelings
towards another group not violence but
just you know and and eventually
violence but let's just take him no
there's no reason for white Americans in
one sense you could argue to be wholly
threatened by a group of black Americans
will they've largely kept impressed but
they do they they they definitely a many
times you start to look at the
unconscious prejudices one of the things
I guess maybe the largest number of
times that Marx is mentioned say that
that if you take the Martian notion of
false consciousness one of the one of
the examples of false consciousness that
we see in modern neuroscience and
psychology is a very stark difference
between people who sit on the top of a
hierarchy implicitly preferring their
own but people who sit at the bottom of
a hierarchy not prefer in their own okay
and so now you have to combine this this
preference for your own and add into
that mixture the additional fact that
it's usually people who come from
privileged groups who seem to show deep
unconscious breakfast for their own but
those who come from
or disadvantaged groups do not show
equivalent preference for their life
it's just interesting talking to Deborah
share on modern because any illustrates
another point which is but it's not as
simple as saying that similarity is
always good and your similarity can
often form the kind of the frame within
which these conflicts kind of Kern's
garage were said but this can be groups
trying to get you know as big a part of
the pie as possible in those most
classic studies from the nineteen
seventies I was talking about earlier by
harmeet article and one of the findings
there was one of the strategies that
people were concerned was maximal
differentiation not maximum Ingrid
profits in other words they were less
concerned about getting as much as
possible of the available resource for
their own group but just making sure
that their own group had more than the
other it was that it was to reinforce
these ideas that there is a symbolic
dimension to group identity as well as
the other dimensions that we've been
talking about
you